Wie viele menschen braucht man eigentlich für die reise zum mit 4,2 lichtjahren entfernung nächstgelegenen exoplaneten
proxima centauri b eine berechtigte frage denn eine crew mit heute üblichen drei astronauten oder
astronauten würden nicht ankommen sondern sie würden vorher sterben was also tun
das rätsel wo sie jetzt gelöst und die lösung erfahrt ihr hier bei pixum science fiction herzlich willkommen
Knapp 7000 zuschauerinnen und zuschauer haben gestern auf unserem kanal an der abstimmung teilgenommen und zu 67
für dieses thema gestimmt mit wie vielen menschen muss man hier von der erde aus starten damit überhaupt jemand auf dem exoplaneten
proxima centauri b
ankommt 3 wie meistens heute üblich das sind zu wenig aber wie viele genau
diese frage haben jetzt frederik macher von der universität straßburg und kamelblut vom forschungsunternehmen
kaskade beantwortet um sie zu beantworten mussten sie erst einmal ein paar voraussetzungen
festlegen unter anderem wie lange dauert eigentlich die reise sie kommen zum schluss dass es mit heutiger technik
6300 jahre dauern würde proxima centauri zu erreichen okay also gibt es schon mal ein kleines problem die stadt
besatzung würde niemals das ziel erreichen und überhaupt würden die meisten besatzungsmitglieder
weder die erde noch proxima centauri geht zum gesicht bekommen es muss also dafür gesorgt werden so die forscherinnen und der forscher dass genügend
besatzungsmitglieder an bord sind die sich zum einen fortpflanzen können und zum anderen um erbschäden zu vermeiden nicht verwandt sein dürfen
bei ihrer simulation mit dem algorithmus heritage
gingen sie davon aus dass sich die besatzung alle 32 bis 40 jahre fort fans zu dem
simulierten sie eine katastrophe bei der ein drittel der besatzung starb dazu kam noch natürliche todesfälle und tödliche unfälle
das ergebnis
es werden 49 paare
beziehungsweise 98 personen für die besatzung benötigt die raumschiffe dielen was für die marsmission plan
hätten also genau die richtige größe ich frage mich allerdings wie die versorgung aussehen soll vorräte für
6300 jahre wird man bekommen mitnehmen können und
selbstversorgung pflanzen die basis dafür
würden im dunkel des weltraums wohl kaum wachsen energie für künstliche beleuchtung wo es weil die kommen
ich freue mich über eure ideen und links zu in den kommentaren ich mache daraus dann ein video in dem ich mit euren in denen
eine solche mission plane ich bin sehr gespannt es gibt aber laut den beiden noch weitere nicht kalkulierbare unwägbarkeiten
verändert sich die fruchtbarkeit im weltall treten durch die kosmische strahlung
mutationen auf gebe es dadurch weniger gesunde kinder dann würde die fortpflanzung nicht mehr funktionieren gibt es dafür aber weniger
katastrophen und unfälle
fragen über fragen also eure ideen in die kommentare und schon bald fliegen wird zumindest virtuell zu proxima centauri
wenn ihr
dieses video und alle anderen videos nicht verpassen wollt dann endet mich bei whatsapp dann umgehend ihr die kaputte a proxy auf youtube und verpasst
kann video denn über whatsapp erfahrt ihr von mir persönlich
von jedem upload und zwar noch vor allen anderen täglich garantiert einfach hier draufklicken und am besten auch meinen
schwesterkanal kriegs um social media abonnieren da gibt es das neueste aus der social media welt aktuelle hat thomas dort den bahn- fall aufgeklärt
dafür hier klicken aber nicht die genau die glocke vergessen und hier geht es weiter mit dafür auch draufklicken
außerirdisches leben auf proxima centauri b bis dann
bleibt dran